at 6 30 here we start with some news
that may make a lot of you very happy
adele
finally announcing her las vegas
residency on twitter about a half hour
ago weekends with adele that was the
original title will now happen november
18th through march 25th inside the
original space the coliseum at caesar's
her residency was supposed to happen
this past january but of course as you
all know it was called off at the last
minute singer says
access will be limited with priority
given to fans who held original tickets
for the show or had previously
registered and been wait listed for the
weekends with the dell verified fan
pre-sale so if you're locked in before
you get first crack at it this time
around it was so hard to even consider
thinking about buying tickets to the
first one 6 30 by the way good morning
it's monday we were talking i remember
before adele was going to play
how expensive the tickets were and it
was this rush and then thousands of
dollars slam the brakes on sherry slam
the brakes well you know fans have to be
happy now that she's finally going to
show up yeah
just show up
positive vibes
positive vibes only okay all right